in this video I'm going to talk about
ctla4 and inhibition of the t-cell
response so we know that the T cells are
actually activated by antigen presenting
cells such as macrophages now macrophage
Express MHC class 2 and MHC class 2 bind
peptides are recognized by T cell
receptor so MHC class 2 and T cell
receptor mediated interaction gives a
stimulatory signal for T cell activation
other than that there are co stimulatory
signals which comes from cdat expressed
on the antigen presenting cell and cd28
expressed on the surface of the t-cell
combinely these two interactions give
the necessary signal to the T cell
nucleus for its activation now once
these signals are received the T cell is
considered to be activated and once the
T cell is activated it would interact
with the B cell and activate the B cell
as well now B cell activation would lead
to production of plasma cells and
thereby antibodies against the pathogen
to neutralize it so T cell receive a
ssin is super important for the immune
system but imagine a situation where T
cells are hyper activated then instead
of helping the body it might make the
situation worse
so we need a safeguard mechanism by
which we can prevent over activation of
the T cells and this kind of mechanisms
are present in the t cell itself two
days later after it is activated it is
found that the T cell surface expressed
a molecule known as CTL f4 which is very
similar to the cd28 molecule now cd28
family molecules are important for our
amour act as they act as a co
stimulatory signal for T cell activation
but the ctla4 do not act as a
co-stimulatory signal instead it acts as
an inhibitory signal in red it is shown
that cdat and ctla-4 can interact and
give a inhibitory signal now not only
cd8 t and c t LF for interaction gives
an negative signal but also it prevents
cd28 to interact with cd8 T so it also
sequester the ligands for the cd28
receptor and that is how it prevents the
T cell activation imagine at a point of
time there are like three cd8 for cdat
present in the antigen presenting cell
now three are occupied or interacting
with cd28 but one is interacting with
ctla-4 now you are having three
stimulatory signals or three unique of
stimuli signal let's put it in this way
and one unit of inhibitory signal so
you're not totally abolish abolishing
the excitatory signal or the
activator e signal but you are putting a
break kind of thing and that is how you
are attenuating the activator e signal
and that is how T cell response or the T
cell activity falls down this is one of
the mechanism other than this mechanism
sometimes the cd8 T and ctla-4 mediated
signaling can give rise to specific
cytokines which are preventing the
activation of further naive cell here a
knife T cell is represented which has
the receptor for this cytokine secreted
by the T cell which is expressing ctla4
and these cytokine mediated signaling
tells this T naive T cell not to get
activated in other words these t cell
activity would be reducing or that over
activity of the T cell can be prevented
by these kind of safeguard mechanisms as
if there is a break always there in the
car right with access
so if you only had accelerator there
might be chances of accident so you
always have a break to prevent the
chances of accident and exact similar
kind of mechanism is present in our
immune system see how beautifully
designed our immune system is apart from
these Siddhi cdat and ctla-4 interaction
which we have looked so far there are
many other these kind of interactions
are found in t-cell and between APCs
APC Express hvem which is another ligand
for PTL a receptor now this btle
receptor is expressed in t-cells and
b-cells and this interaction is all also
inhibitory other than that PDL 1 and PDL
2 are the two ligands for the receptor
PD 1 expressed in t-cell both these
interactions are inhibitory in nature
and trying to bring down the hyper
activation or the possibility of hyper
activation of the t-cells and in this
way our immune system has designed a
mechanism by which it does not affect
its own body by hyper activation and
this is also a mechanism of Tolerance so
I hope you enjoyed this video if you
liked this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you